hello reject nation it's greg alba here
and i'm john and i'm andrew andrew from
the movie source channels here with us
today i'm excited for this game because
i have played the first three plus a
quarter maybe less of Metal Gear Solid
four that being the quarter one one two
and three I played and this is some
Hideo Kojima John's played oh yeah the
same exact amount of ever here I have
Andrew hasn't played them some expert
why some experts sorry guys still stuck
on Last of Us in Batman Arkham games I'm
still bummed out silent hill's didn't
well gamma the tour was supposed to be
in this and Norman Reedus is in this too
now I'm intrigued we're always making it
louder tube so we can hear the train
[Music]
in that space once there was an
explosion a bang which gave rise to life
as we know it and then came to the next
explosion
does that Norman Reedus knocking yeah
definitely see this guy's voice sounds
cool so you soon as Darrel accent Wow
Porter oceanic school looks like an
alien's LV
[Music]
whoa what is happening
Oh No
Oh No ooh
[Music]
it's like an invisible creature John
scared
[Music]
with the deaths or anything
whoa whoa that's so scary
I detect you my hair
whoa oh my goodness
I shot I mean sad for the friendship and
all
whoa what
Oh maybe it's like the last baby a lot
about everything I've ever heard about
it's like the last baby live or
something
wait a minute the award ever get all me
like a children and that premise
situation yeah whoa
he's throw the baby in the hole
whoa what is going on
[Music]
this is from one long tracking shot
yes I think so
now asked to take care of this baby
crabs
oh my god
[Music]
but I didn't make his body overly buff
yeah
maybe like that he'd Norman Reedus I
mean he's buff
Oh
[Music]
what is that looks like a combination of
like a scorpion
so Wilfred yeah it's kinda like power so
they cared me in three Assassin's Creed
character what on earth's how I think he
swallowed the baby
so cool
music
yeah music
oh man once there was an explosion
that will be our glass Mads Mikkelsen -
that sounds exciting yeah Star Tours
thank you make ice and fire
oh boy that made me want to play a video
game again that was really interesting
because it had me thinking about when I
would play the Metal Gear games and I
always liked how everyone of the Metal
Gear games you never go into that game
thinking it's a horror game but each one
of them has an element in there that is
very much horror based I remember there
was like Psycho Mantis which was super
like horror and then you have the vamp
in Metal Gear yeah you got like
weird-ass characters part 3 yeah but
those games aren't like horror games and
this has this sci-fi horror vaya - it
feels it feels scary I know they didn't
have silent hill's go through but he's
getting a chance to do his other project
that still seems to have the horror
element be a strong factor in it oh
definitely and I love it I love cuz you
know like Metal Gear always starts off
like it's just a mission and then it
gets all freaking weird you know yeah
this is just like it's weird weird right
away yeah and and we got to protect this
baby I guess yeah that's gotta be a
strange accessory to have on you in a
video game I wonder if you're gonna have
like to live you're kind of like a baby
life party I forgot everything I learned
about the gate as a massage chair for
this a long-ass time ago and rather
being a baby in there and I also like
this idea because I've thought about
that you know there were dinosaurs then
there were humans I know there's you
know some other animals in between I
will be the next thing and I like how
this game touches on that the whole
concept is about yeah the next big thing
what would emerge in humanity would go
extinct maybe that baby's the last
chance of humanity yeah well and this
also kind of reminded this is a weird
reference to pull but it kind of
reminded me of that
inch nails out in Year Zero with like
the creepy figures and this sort of
dystopian and and you can tell they're
from some kind of outfit organized and
they have these suits with their Mane at
least I think it's his name or something
what I liked about this trailer was its
how heart pumps how heartfelt and heart
pumping it felt like what I mean by that
is like through the the tension-filled
scenes like you're really like what the
hell is going on and just you feel like
the threat level detention level just
it's got a lot of horror vibes which I
appreciated but I think the biggest
thing that I thought on top of the
incredible visuals that we see cuz these
I mean the visual of Norman Reedus it
looks just like image yeah like you but
what I'm appreciating of this even
though it doesn't really go into it
crazy detail the story it kinda is very
vague story wise it looks like there is
gonna be a really interesting story just
from the little snippets we're getting
with the baby and like you know what's
gonna be doing with that you know the
the thought of you know they're gonna be
in a different world or like the a dead
world like I mean the the visual you
know imagery that I can think of that
we're gonna see in that world it's just
gonna be mind trippin because obviously
I know Guillermo del Toro right is
working they worked on this game that
didn't end up going through called
silent hill's
I don't know if you know the Toro is
involved in it in terms of the making of
it I think it might be done sort of in
the likeness of Guillermo del Toro well
I feel like this is nice that they're
both involved in this because even
though this is very different from
Silent Hill it does have a certain
Silent Hill ish like breathy s and and
like weirdness about it cuz you're
watching this and you're going like this
is messed up I think but I can't quite
tell what it is and it's freaky and and
some of the most potent video games to
me anyway are the ones that do play on
tension and fear and they can get your
heart rate going and especially with the
advances we've made in VR and stuff I
imagine this would be a very intense oh
yeah gameplay situation because we were
sitting there and like those long camera
shots and stuff you're like starting to
get uneasy and and also this makes me
wonder now what the gameplay is gonna
actually be like I really thought the
world - really
a lot of lv-426 and aliens yeah give me
just especially the night time seems
like I was really a vibing like just to
be back in like a world that feels like
that I'm like really hooked into this
it's interesting to watch the
annihilation trailer and then watch this
and you're like they're not too far
parked they could be cousins yeah
just add you know like 200-foot
Slenderman and what was that I wonder if
this game will actually say what they
are yeah I'm sure we'll find out
something and I mean like oh did you see
some of those early shots were like
they're hidden in the background are you
seeing the ripples of the clouds more of
them and they're like oh I was also
getting a little bit of vibe and miss
amidst yeah I was really a Frank
Darabont's the mrs. Carrie out of the
Mist budget with the big creature in the
sky like yeah yeah I was getting a lot
of that it's that creature that crawls
over the surface of the water definitely
had a missed vibe to me all the
creatures in that movie have an
insect-like design oh yeah and and that
made me wonder too because that's a
different design from the big tall
figure dance who are around I wonder if
this is just the tip of the iceberg in
terms of what strange stuff we're gonna
zest and also I loved how they were
building the suspense just showing like
the footprints and something you can't
see there like that's just scary to me
something I cannot even see it's like
how the hell are we supposed to you know
kill or defeat something we can't even
see we yeah see some foot princess I
wonder how you will define that how the
game will specifically define how the
rules of these creatures are if they are
the creatures as what would you call it
in how intellectual are they I don't
they're just be monsters you see their
intellectual beings they seem like
they're functioning on a higher realm
yeah and obviously we'll have to see
what happens gameplay wise when the game
comes out but I just feel like the way
they're building it up slowly it's like
it feels like they're gonna be very
difficult to beat and I like it when we
face you know not only in movies with
video games as well when you get to
defeat villains who are really tough to
fight the payoff is just so satisfying
like damn I really earned that in the
end so that's I'm hoping that it really
like ends up being that because that's
what I was getting the vibe of you know
just off the few little clips we're
seeing of these guys I'm like how we're
supposed to defeat these characters now
I like that sense like you know feeling
like it's gonna be impossible one and
are we supposed to or is the point sort
of to get clever and elude because this
is also an open-world game so you can
kind of go I imagine any
and and you know now I'm thinking like
and you know upside-down world yeah yeah
now I'm thinking like are we gonna have
like a fall out sort of thing where
you're like wandering from like little
encampment to encampment like I think
coming across creatures and then making
little alliances or what I think you
just also mentioned one things like I'm
oh I'm really looking forward to if we
do play this game is the open world just
a little what we saw here of I couldn't
tell which world they were if they were
in the dying world whatever but I mean
just I'm very excited at the
possibilities of other worlds that we
can get get to see like visual imagery
wise this was outstanding to look at its
it's amazing where they've come to video
games it really is it really is it
really is ladies plus you know maybe one
of these days they'll do like a
demagogue and DLC and you can you can
fight one what's the strangest things
reference Andrew cuz of the upside down
world I need to get on that the upside
down guys you can subscribe to the real
rejects please click that notification
bell Andrew is on the movie source
channel follow him there because he
loves movies we love movies who doesn't
love movies have you ever met someone
who said I don't like movies you know
who says that people who watch movies
that are cynical they're still watching
movies can become a picture on jected AG
for that take care